Ai and fantasy football and a look at
generative AI tools being used by
criminals all on this episode of IBM
Tech now what's up y'all my name is Ian
and I am back to bring you the latest
and greatest news and announcements
about IBM
technology the NFL season is in full
swing and if you're one of the estimated
60 million Americans who play Fantasy
Football you're likely spending a lot of
time pouring over stats and stories to
find that edge and if you're one of the
many like me whose fantasy team is
struggling you could probably use a
little help luckily for you IBM partners
with ESPN Fantasy Football to use AI
models built with Watson X to provide 11
million fantasy managers with a data AI
infused experience that transcends
traditional
statistics the AI models built with
Watson X ingest and analyze millions of
news stories opinion Pieces by fantasy
experts and reports on player injuries
the models are expected to produce more
than 40 48 billion insights for Fantasy
managers this year including
recommending trade opportunities and
identifying waiver wire players two key
types of player insights are now
integrated into the ESPN Fantasy
Football app waiver grades and trade
grades using neural networks and
advanced natural language processing
waiver grades give a personalized rating
for the value a player would add to your
team this nuanced algorithm delves deep
into your roster to make realistic
projections based B on your team's
fluctuating strengths and weaknesses
trade grades are another new feature
that helps managers assess the value of
potential trades when managers initiate
transactions with each other the AI
models serve up trade insights featuring
a grade for each athlete involved in the
trade and a grade for the trade's
overall value managers can also use the
AI models to analyze structured and
unstructured data to compare players
estimate the potential upside and
downside of starting a particular player
and assess the impact of an injury to
learn more and start leading your
fantasy team on the journey to the
playoffs check out the link in the
description of this
video next up generative AI chat Bots
like chat gbt that are based on large
language models or llms took the World
by storm this year unfortunately
malicious hackers moved quickly to
exploit these new AI resources using
chat GPT itself to polish and produce
fishing
emails now luckily mainstream llms have
guardrails to prevent their use for
scams and criminality but cyber
criminals are a resourceful bunch and a
range of AI tools designed specifically
for malicious cyber attacks have begun
to
emerge right now the leading brand is
called worm GPT it's an AI module based
on the gptj language model and is
already being used in business email
compromise attacks and for other
nefarious uses until now the most common
way for people to identify fraudulent
fishing email emails was by their
suspicious wording and grammatical
errors but now users can simply type in
instructions for the creation of fraud
emails for example they could input
write an email coming from a bank that's
designed to trick the recipient into
giving up their login credentials the
tool then produces a unique well-written
and usually grammatically perfect email
that's far more convincing than what
most attackers would write on their own
in general these generative AI tools are
used for boosting three aspects of cyber
text fishing researching intelligence
about potential victims and writing code
these tools are still in their nent
stages and the threat they represent is
still fairly minimal but the rise of
malicious llms represents a new arms
race between AI that attacks an AI that
defends to learn more hit the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM techn if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
todate on what's going on in Tech
now